Frank do you have any questions that
you'd like to ask Jessica Kherson Noam
in the corner here Frank does he have a
problem he literally is like a you want
a crayon
Frank what would you like to ask Jessica
what'd you have for breakfast this
morning what didn't I have I had the
publicist cuz I'm very important brought
me a Starbucks oatmeal with a pad of
butter which is weird but I love oatmeal
with butter you really yeah do you drop
that also no I know I ate it very fast
before I came in it's good to eat before
a day a press gives you some carbs some
energy yeah with some nuts was there
anything specific that you wanted to ask
you about breakfast and breakfast
sandwiches yeah have you ever heard of a
pork roll does he work for free he does
okay then I can't be too mean that's
horrible a pork roll yep or pork roll or
as some people would call it Mamie
Taylor ham there's no double entendre
here there's no about the breakfast I
will explain when I know about Taylor
ham but first I need to know where are
you going after this to a home like
where this job why he's an intern so his
internship
there's no college credits oh what
college you go to rampu Rambow College
of New Jersey okay that sounds great
[Laughter]
Taylor ham is actually love Taylor ham
egg and cheese sandwiches I used to eat
them when I was in high school I would
get really high and good so that's what
you call us Taylor ham yeah I don't call
if I it was called pork roll I would not
eat it Wow Frank where are you landing
on that not too happy about that answer
but everyone has their opinion right why
is it so important to you that it's
called a pork roll
[Laughter]
I guess it was and be emotional like get
down to the real feelings about it don't
be on the surface it's safe here I guess
it was when I went to college is when I
really found out there was a huge debate
and I ordered a porker one day and some
people went down my throat and I'm like
alright if they actually went down your
threating hot how much that cost you
when it happened I'm joking
all right so okay so bothered you well
so ya know they're just yawning I was
like already forget me I'll go the other
way it's poor crow I mean if you're
gonna it's literally called a Taylor
pork roll on the Box Hill looking at me
while you're talking which is offensive
I'm just telling you I mean there are
people and he has been asking he has to
be the same question this morning and
Rob thinks it's Taylor ham and he swears
it's pork roll it's not it is Taylor ham
it's okay if unique to get more friends
to say pork roll than just say pork roll
and it's not a bit either like I don't
think he realized that you know doing
something until like we listened to a
few of the things he was doing and
realized that just about every person he
was coming into contact with we just
realized it today yeah that everyone and
I scream to contact with he was asking
him is it pork roll or Taylor ham and
all he wanted to talk about was pork I
said four crawls yeah I know it is pork
roll really yes tell him about you grow
up Central Jersey do you believe in that
I'm being totally serious are you okay
yeah okay we're in Central Jersey why
wouldn't I believe that like where do
you think I think you're from know if
you know us you believe him he said do
you believe in Central Jersey yeah he
asked me like if I believe in it like I
believe in the higher power
I do you believe in Santa No do you
believe in Central Jersey no a lot of
people deny that it exists yeah there
are Central Jersey deniers if there's
Jersey there's a center there's a center
of everything this I were on the same
page now so people don't believe you
when you say you're from Central Jersey
rob is one of those people
hey go like this that
doesn't exist it couldn't possibly they
think it's North and South oh no there's
wealth there's a north and a south
there's a center what is going on you're
dealing with think about a lot yeah one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]